[Music]
the lp body museum I really think is an
icon for the City of New Haven for the
state of Connecticut and for New England
it's where so many people and I count
myself as well
learned about the world around us
understood our place in the universe
[Music]
puzzle collections at the Peabody are
amazing they just are but also we have a
lot of bursts and not a lot of museums
can say that we have a lot of what are
called holotypes so it's the first
specimen ever found of that dinosaur for
example and that is first of all very
exciting and second you start thinking
about it and it's every single other one
that it's ever been found has been
described based on our collection
one of the key
parts of this whole project
is the the fossil Hall Burk Hall is is
the heart of the Peabody Museum
some of the first ever fossil mounts are
being reworked to be displayed to you
know the next generation of Museum
visitors with regard to our upcoming
renovation due to open in 2024 we've had
the fortune of working with research
casting International who's based up in
Trenton Ontario Canada and they are
professional firm who brings to us
expertise and skill in mounting
specimens particularly the very large
bounce that are here at the Peabody
they helped us with the installation
removing these large specimens from
their original Mount posture in the hall
and also with the conservation
we're working with them to revise the
pose as well as integrate new materials
into these mounts to make them the most
complete possible the reason why we
wanted to do this is first of all we
want to update our knowledge the science
doesn't stop and so we want to be
updated second all materials age and so
I think we came in at the right time to
do a lot of this work a lot of this
treatment and preparation to prevent any
damage that could have happened in the
future
[Music]
Trenton Ontario is a small town about an
hour and a half east of Toronto we're
located on the Bay of Quinte which is
kind of the gateway to the trend Severn
Waterway
[Music]
very scenic
a lot of tourists come here in the
summer
it's away from the sound in the hub of
Toronto but like we're a nice quiet
community
it is a bit of a contrast what we do in
here and and what the scenery is like
outside it's like a boating and kind of
vacation area
and then we have heavy steel work going
on
and giant dinosaurs and all sorts of
creatures a lot of people are surprised
when they hear what we do in here I
don't think anybody realized what we
actually do
[Music]
we are research cast International right
now we're about a 50 000 square feet
for the employees and we've been in
business uh 35 years companies that do
what we do you're probably counting the
one hand of all the companies in the
world that do this sort of thing we're
probably the largest for the Yale
Peabody project we're doing a number of
specimens
um which are pretty amazing like this
article on we've been looking at for a
long time it's one of our favorite uh
specimens in one of mine specifically is
the brontosaur that we're doing and you
know having things that were collected
by Marsh and getting to work on them are
pretty amazing uh thing to be able to do
it's pretty iconic I think it's um just
because we get to to work on these these
massive creatures and the Brontosaurus
itself is when I think of a dinosaur
that's the first dinosaur I think of and
a lot of kids feel that way we're very
excited to work on it it's it's pretty
it's pretty cool work
[Music]
when we start a project we do all the
cleaning and conservation preparation
first each person has their own station
and they work on an individual component
of a specimen we usually start off by
cleaning the dinosaur bones with
chemicals like acetone ethanol and
sometimes alcohol so we start by
removing any of the grime or dust that
has been built up on the specimen and
then sometimes we use an air scribe too
to remove old posture that's been
covering the bones there's lots of steps
involved and then that would go to the
blacksmith
[Music]
once the bones come from the preparators
and they're all cleaned and Consolidated
they store them in the storage area in
our room and we move them to our sandbox
as you can see here
they're supported in the sandbox and
then we start measuring for an Armature
obviously this being a historically
significant
fossil we have to take a lot of care to
preserve it and preserve all the all the
numbering and markings on it and and the
history behind it these armatures
protect the bone it also doesn't destroy
any of the fossil it's not invasive and
you can remove any bone from the mount
that way
after all the armatures are done we
build the support
steal for it and and we start building
the pose
so all of these armatures get welded
together into the desired hose it's
going to look a lot more Dynamic it
looks more in motion than it did before
the white was fascinating
just take very small changes in the way
that the head is positioned or that the
tail is bent and turned this is revised
by new research and it's informed by new
collections we try to find fossils and
increase the data set available to us to
study and interpret how an organism may
have changed in time what its paleo
environment may have been like what its
Locomotion may have been like
[Music]
all of the tremendous science that's
been done over the past many decades is
informing what we're able to do for this
um this next generation of display we've
got great Partners who are helping us do
that working with RCI
work is one of the highest standards
when it comes to the materials and the
techniques that they use and the care
that they bring to our materials we as
an institution have entrusted RCI with
our most precious specimens and they in
return are really taking this material
to the next level and presenting it to
the world in such a way that it will be
enjoyed and learned from for years to
come knowing that the work that I'm
doing now is going to be up for another
century is uh it's pretty humbling that
I've been given this opportunity to work
on such a historically significant
animal and and uh it's pretty amazing
that my work is going to outlast me I
just hope that 90 years from now people
like me and paleontologists will look at
it and be like they did it they did a
good job
working on the Yelp by program it's been
a blessing yeah like it's been a really
really nice project to work on this was
the beginning of paleontology you know
and these specimens that we're working
on were these specimens that
started on the paleontology on that road
all the history behind it all in my mind
is is just amazing
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]